That was a big one.
I think your boss would be proud of the
progress you've made on this prototype.
Here's one last request though,
she wants to see two new features.
She doesn't want to hold you back just
create what you think would add the most
value to this application.
Then, after making sure that your
code quality is up to snuff, and
that your code runs as expected,
your boss, and
the Udacity code reviewers, want to know
what you learned during this process.
In your project repository, we want
you to create a reflections file, and
write about your experiences
working on this.
We want you to answer
the following questions.
How long did you spend
working on this project?
What was the most rewarding
challenge you conquered?
What new features did you build and why?
And where do you still have room for
growth?
Lastly take a step back and
look at what you've just created and
compare this to Toy City One.
It may feel like there's still a long
way to go before you're making web apps.
But just look how far you've come.
Keep this momentum up and way to go.